okay so our last event of the day is
going to be introduced by Melanie Maxon
the director of research support and
outreach programs at CSS si all right
well it's it's very exciting to be able
to introduce the next the next and final
talk at this year's day of data with a
demonstration and talked by some of our
colleagues at sighs City the center of
Center for innovative thinking at Yale
and so our speakers are Martin Weinstein
who is an innovator in residence at the
size Center for innovative thinking at
Yale where he leads the Yale open
innovation lab he is also a research
associate in the Yale Department of
Electrical Engineering and a research
affiliate in the MIT Media Lab
he received his PhD from the University
of Melbourne Australian German climate
and energy college he is active in a
variety of entrepreneurship projects
related to sustainability and with
Martin is Sophie janeski who is an
environmental and innovation fellow Co
appointed at size city and at the Yale
Center for business in the environment
she works on environmental
entrepreneurship at Yale and is a
graduate of both Yale College and the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies she's previously
served as a fellow with venture for
America a two-year program that provides
training for entrepreneurs so if things
are set up and ready to go
I will turn it over to Martin and Sophie
wonderful thank you so much for that
introduction and thank you so much for
everyone for sticking around to listen
to us give the the last talk of the day
we're really excited to be here and are
very grateful for the invitation we're
gonna be setting up some things just at
the beginning of this talk so don't
don't mind the sort of activity at the
front of the room we've got a little bit
of a VR demonstration that Martine is
gonna lead at the end of the talk so
something exciting to keep your
attention but as I was saying we're
really excited to be here at the day of
data to share the ways in which we and
our students at the Center for
innovative thinking at Yale are engaging
with data in entrepreneurial and
innovative ways and in terms of our sort
of agenda for the talk first I'm going
to give a little bit of an introduction
to size City as we call it for those in
the room who may not be familiar as we
are relatively new Center I'm so just
going to give a little bit of context
about our our Center and some of the
programs that we're working on then
I excited to highlight a number of our
student projects and programs who are
engaging with data in ways that are
particularly relevant for today's theme
for data on earth and then I'm going to
actually hand it over to Martine who's
going to talk a little bit more about
our labs and initiatives that are being
incubated out of size City particularly
the open lab which is doing some really
exciting work on emerging technologies
and data and applying them to earth
scale challenges particularly in the
energy and climate fields and then as I
mentioned we're going to close out with
a little bit of a VR demonstration
but there's a little bit of background
for foresight city just to familiarize
launched in the fall of 2015 sigh city
is building a new center of gravity for
students faculty and alumni to
collaborate more effectively across
disciplines endeavours and ways of
thinking about the world generally so
our core commitments are to
interdisciplinary collaboration
inclusion across every dimension of
diversity the conviction that we can
turn rigorous thought and creativity
into effective action and the fostering
of resilience and one of the main ways
in which we do this is via programming
so this is sort of a high-level overview
of a number of the different types of
programming that we've been
experimenting with over the past year
and a half now and so we again offer a
number of ways to explore and engage
with tons of different topics so there
are folks who are working on you know
coming from all across campus all the
different disciplines all different
backgrounds working together on teams
and I want to take a moment to sort of
walk through some examples of teams who
are specifically engaging with data so
we see this a lot in our sort of like
more learning and building oriented
activities and so in terms of
highlighting those I'm gonna start with
build and so I mean when we say build is
when our programs that are guiding
students and teams with innovative ideas
through the process of actually building
out organizations projects ventures we
provide support through workshop
mentoring funding those types of things
but again we're not strictly focused on
just for-profit ventures we are focused
sort of across the board although I
think both of the the teams I'm gonna
highlight right now are actually
for-profit ventures so the first team I
want to highlight as part of our was was
part of our 2018 fall accelerator so
this was a six-week program that ran
co-curricular release of full time
students were in this program and we're
giving up their Friday's to sort of work
on their on their projects
and this team is called Brie omics there
are a team of four graduate biology PhDs
and their innovation is to use DNA
sequencing data and analysis to help
farmers make smarter decisions regarding
their crop choice irrigation
fertilization and the application of
microbial inoculants so the their vision
here is that the data that they collect
and analyze and synthesize and sort of
provide tailored insights around I was
going to be useful in developing new
advanced microbial inoculants so for
example if the DNA sequencing revealed
that a field lacked a particular
beneficial you know set of beneficial
microbes that they could make a
tailor-made recommendation on which
microorganisms needed to be applied to
the field so this is a really exciting
example of a team sort of taking their
expertise in genetics and biology and
thinking about how to synthesize with
that with data to apply in sort of an
entrepreneurial context the next team I
want to quickly highlight came out of
our summer fellowship so this was a full
time I believe it was a 10-week program
or eight to ten weeks where students
were working over the summer to on
different entrepreneurial ventures and
projects and this team is called
visionary health it's co-founded by a
student at the the Yale public health
school and they're developing artificial
intelligence powered solutions to make
healthcare deliver less expensive and
more reliable so it's actually really
interesting that I think whenever the
earlier talks was sort of alluding to to
these types of solutions so we have one
of our students who's actively working
on building that out so they're
essentially building an automated image
screening platform which is capable of
autonomously examining medical images
with the idea being that they can
effectively identify which images are
you have the potential for having
abnormalities
so that radiologist can really focus on
those and sort of the the images that
are most clinically clinically relevant
so some really exciting work of being
done on that front and so the next set
of programming it kind of wants you
touch on is are sort of more learning
oriented programming so not all students
are coming in whizzes at sort of deep
wet learning techniques or genetic you
know genomic sequencing but we have
students who are really interested in
taking you know perhaps some of their
more humanistic backgrounds or liberal
arts knowledge and trying to learn
technical skills and be able to sort of
mesh the two together and that's
something that we're really really
particularly exciting about us getting
these people you know really deeply
involved or have such a deep set of
expertise and how might we be able to
you provide opportunities for learning
to apply a new skills to that knowledge
base and so one of the programs I'd love
to highlight is an Internet of Things
intensive so Sai city runs intensive
which are such a co-curricular deep
dives into topics that that students are
interested in oftentimes these last four
to six weeks meeting once a week for you
know two to three hours at a time and so
this Internet of Things intensive as
students explored the interconnections
via the Internet of different computing
devices that are embedded in everyday
objects that you know send and receive
data and so this was led by our mentor
and residents Levi DeLuca's actually a
Yale college graduate who taught some of
the basics of the theory best practices
examples of different IOT system design
and then teams actually formed and and
and students worked on projects that
included integrating sensors data
processing wireless communications and
outputs over the course of the intensive
and one of the teams that I'd like to
highlight on this
front it's one that we were actually
very excited about because it came out
of a specific request from the city of
New Haven so I was a really amazing way
to engage with some of the local
expertise here they needed a way to
detect the water level inside storm
systems in order to collect some data
that was really important for some of
their their city models and some of the
existing commercial products just
weren't weren't meeting their needs so
they they partnered with one of the
teams in this intensive to develop a
prototype of an IOT device that takes an
analog voltage reading from a sensor and
codes it so that it can be a sent
efficiently over our long range data
communication channel and then is
processed saved on a server and that's
accessible to the folks who are needing
it for further modeling so that was sort
of a really exciting application that
some of our students got to you know
learn some brand new stuff and
immediately apply it and then lastly I
want to just as a quick note highlight I
don't have necessarily any students a
specific products a highlight from this
effort but blockchain was mentioned
earlier I think the last talk so I
thought I'd give a little bit of a
shout-out here too so at the end of
September we hosted a two-day blockchain
bootcamp
that had over 125 participants hosted up
in Kroon Hall through panel discussions
and two tracks so the the the real goal
of this blockchain bootcamp was to teach
participants and sort of jumpstart their
technical skill building in blockchain
development via hands-on training we had
two pedagogical partners from you know
consensus Academy by Academy coming to
lead workshops at different levels for
students who you know we're interested
in building out some of those skill sets
and moving forward we're excited to
continue some of continue some of these
approaches I think we got feedback that
students found this really valuable and
it was really exciting for me for me to
hear and some of the previous talks some
of this
that we're looking to sort of build up
on campus so if there's any room for
collaboration on that front we'd be
really excited about it and with that I
would love to hand it over now to
Martine Weinstein who's going to give
you a little bit more of a background on
some of our labs and initiatives and
then sit tight for the the VR
demonstration Thank You Sophie thanks
again everyone for for hosting us it's
amazing that we're finally here being
that we've been talking about David data
since early in the semester so and we we
also discussed the possibility of
running this demo that I'll just explain
a bit of what's happening
Bobby berry here is actually one of the
students very much engaged with us and
and has also been part of an intensive
like Sophie explained around virtual
reality and so what we're doing is just
calibrating the sensors from these two
towers and this will happen over the
last part of the talk I will also try to
see if I can oh I think we lost the USB
that connects to this clicker won't work
so so once that was it done amazing Oh
[Applause]
yeah I mean it looks just like like a
data USB so a lot of what Sophia
explained relates to our semester-long
programs you know we're very much
student facing but this year we also
tried to consolidate longer term
programs for students to participate
beyond a semester and we call those our
labs and our initiatives we we have
currently three main labs and
initiatives the knowledge equity
initiative is led by world fellow
Baljeet Sandhu and focuses on being able
to value in a meaningful and equitable
way learnings from lived experiences
from social change makers we at Yale is
is an amazing campus wide series very
well established to showcase and inspire
women entrepreneurship and what I'll
talk about today is the open innovation
lab which I'll showcase three projects
that are particularly relevant around
around data and near Earth so we thought
it was relevant for this and and the
logic of the open lab in many ways is to
try to leverage radical collaboration
for disruptive projects that we can
incubate and get students to participate
on that involved multi-stakeholder
partnerships in in two main intersection
between large earth system challenges
and emerging technology in terms of
Earth's system challenges our focus has
mostly been through the last year and
probably at least one more year on
climate and energy transition and the
Paris agreement and what can we do
around this topic and in terms of
emerging technology one of the key
things that wouldn't be a surprise is
blotching because part of our perhaps
intuition among the series of
emerging tech is that it might be able
to develop innovative governance
structures for collaboration to happen
and even though we'll also talk about we
are we also have kind of on the side how
to be able to bring in open source crowd
content development in VR using using
blockchain so in this sort of three
intersection points comes opportunities
using some system thinking to see what
are leverage points that disruptive
projects can emerge in the context of of
open innovation meaning that everything
we do is publish either Creative Commons
or open source licensees for also the
world to share and replicate and within
that project tract there's three things
that I want to highlight today one is a
project that we're working on how to use
blocks into finance solar systems
another one is a new project we're
calling open earth collab Assange and
finally the energy Academy where we're
gonna deep dive into into the are now
these three projects are tied also to
are also semester-long programs in the
case of watching first marshal of
finance we do a working group we meet
every Thursday on the CID the the collab
asan's our open open events than anyone
can join and for VR we we did run an
intensive this semester and I also I'm
gonna highlight specific things about
these projects relative to data rather
than going into each one in full detail
because they are kind of like world on
on their own and and I will start with
with the one on the left and one of the
probably the few things that you you
might bring out of that is that each
project always tries to have a
collaboration with both inside Yale and
out and outside partnerships so that's
that's in many ways an ethos of city is
to be a glue of many multidisciplinary
centers already at Yale so with the
first project where we're doing a
research and development and how to use
blockchain for Finance is actually
inspired by Hurricane Maria when it hit
for
in September last year leaving the or
exposing the vulnerability of the energy
system and this is a project that
started at the digital currency
initiative at the MIT Media Lab and then
we've been leading it since February in
partnership with them and also led us to
collaborate with the innovation office
of Puerto Rico very interested in this
in this project in a nutshell one of the
key things that we're trying to test and
develop is take solar assets to say
solar panels that are you know they can
be financed and use again Internet of
Things data so sensors of power meters
that are connected to the Internet and
broadcast them to smart contracts on a
blockchain now a blockchain is a
decentralized ledger wherein in many
ways the particularity is that no one
has total control over that information
but at the same time everyone has to
have consensus of what's in there
a smart contract is let's say a piece of
code that lives on a blockchain and
execute actions or transactions between
between peers if certain variables are
or agreements are actually matched and
so it does it automatically therefore if
we put kind of these that the IOT data
and the smart contract concept we're
able to execute automatically for
example as payments a tariff a price per
kilowatt hour certificates of carbon of
renewable energy that was generated and
in many ways a blockchain is a
decentralized attempt stamping system of
what just happened so it's like this
just happened this entry renewable
energy was generated this carbon was
displaced and this has led us to propose
financial mechanisms to even leverage
for example municipal bonds to transform
puerto rico's 800 public schools and to
be solar-powered emergency shelters
taking a loss so in parallel to this
project we said well why don't we we
also test some things you're at home and
so one of the things that we've been
doing and is is trying to think about
how we can take the renewable energy
assets
here at Yale and use these proof of
concepts to also produce certificates of
the carbon that is displays for example
from the solar panels at crude Hall or
the wind turbines and the Beck tone
building and just last week a couple of
students finished the electronics on one
of the printed circuit board floor for
those IOT power meters and I think next
week we're going to be already putting
this together in Kroon Hall and started
to even think about how we can transact
almost carbon value between between
buildings let me go to the next project
that is also quite new and it's also
around blotching and data consensus so
the what the mission that inspires this
project is is the one of the major
challenges that comes out of Paris
agreement having a 1.5 degree
temperature target implies that we
really have a physical limit in our
atmosphere and and that is our single
planetary carbon budget and in many ways
a single budget almost requires a single
ledger to keep track of it and so our
hypotheses is well can we leverage blog
chains decentralized consensus and
record-keeping abilities and apply it to
the tracking between parties that as we
know don't necessarily trust each other
because there's a lot of there's a lot
of vested interest in being able to emit
more in that quarter and so with that in
mind which is definitely not an easy
thing to do and and and and not
something to do overnight
well we think about is well why don't we
do a series of collaborative hackathons
that build on each other and and we
start by starting to explore pieces of
the puzzle towards being able to have
almost like an earth carbon ledger and
so we start with data data oracles which
I'll explain soon and then going into
climate action tracking for example by
non-state actors let's say New Haven
wants to be carbon neutral by 2045 and
there has to be a record of that and
ways of tracking that so these are all
things that also lead up to some of the
capabilities that would be needing for
something like that and then eventually
we could conceive of working on a carbon
ledger that would be probably very
useful for the UNF Triple C for example
before going into Data Oracle's this is
how we've conceived this concept of a
collab athan it starts with the design
sprint multiple experts coming together
and understanding the problem even
thinking or reframing the problem I da
ting deciding on on a prompt or a
technical architecture of something that
then will move towards more like a open
source product sprint that involves a
collaborative coding contest think about
a hackathon where and a hackathon
everyone is working on their code and
and and the winner takes all in a
competition to a running code that
everyone sees and and every time you
improve something about the code you
take a leading board so this is
something that was worked a lot by by
mathworks would that develops MATLAB and
we've been we've been and we're working
with them on trying to develop something
like that we think something some like
this might be also be interesting on how
to work on collective global problems in
a collaborative way so I'm gonna go to
just what we're running next week
literally it's our first design sprint I
suppose very initial steps and it's not
very similar not very different from
what I explained in the Puerto Rico case
where we have solar assets IOT data and
smart contracts what data Oracle's do on
a on a on a blockchain smart contract is
sit right there in between let's say we
have a bet - what's the price of oil in
the next coming months and and there's
some money and that someone has to
verify that was met or not so normally
the way would go is to a banking or a
trusted institution that is going to
attest about what happened in the future
or maybe in the past so if you have
smart digitalized contracts you need
almost like a trusted Oracle which is
almost like a an abstract computer
that's going to attest to something and
then verify it to the smart contract and
in many ways what we're trying to work
on that concept is how do we do that - a
test on the marginal carbon displace per
unit of new clean energy
because eventually a ledger that keeps
track of a carbon budget needs to be
executed like records to do almost like
a contract and so this is an area and
I'm not gonna go into the the details of
it but we're we're excited about what
comes comes after after our first
designs of bread so with that we're
gonna go even deeper into the virtual
world into a project that we've started
incubating in this summer actually
around July called the energy Academy
and we've been incubating this with the
Center for collaborative arts and media
so in many sense it's so what I'm going
to show you is only there's only been
since the summer and it kind of tacitly
suggests how fast it is to develop in in
in the world of mixed reality I don't
want to talk too much before we we jump
into a demo because it should be kind of
self-explanatory but there's a couple of
remarks that I wanted to do the first is
this might be common for some people but
I just want to make a clear distinction
when we talk about mixed reality there's
almost like a family term that has both
virtual reality and augmented reality
virtual reality its characteristic is
it's a fully immersive environment and
there's two ways of experiencing mixed
reality reality is to do your phone
based had said or a fully computer
connected had said like an HTC vive
--let's that's there and has sensors and
has to be connected to a computer that
has a large graphical processing unit at
least that's how we know the technology
today I mean it's changing very fast
augmented reality superimposes the three
3d digital world on our real world so
it's a lot more interactive I can see
you as you will see when I put on the
headset I I'll stop seeing you and you
might leave the room and I won't even
find out augmented reality has a lot of
applications but one of the things that
we also find is that developing in VR
really helps us think on applications
for AR the second thing I wanted to say
is one of the things that inspired this
project was a big picture concept of how
energy flows to implant
earth through a large Santi diagram that
the global carbon energy program of
Sanford developed and and when I saw
this maybe ten years ago I said wouldn't
it be nice to turn these into visual
journeys at least if we just focus on
solar energy and how it flows to planet
Earth so that we decant a large Sankey
diagram into journeys that one can
understand you know how it how energy
connects us all in many ways in space
and time and particularly being able to
test whether we can bring in contact
through through scales and two nested
systems and scales and so I'll try to
show a bit of what our first prototypes
around this and because the concept was
so varied of being able to understand
how energy flows through planet Earth to
say well let's build a whole campus for
it and each dome will have its own
experience and but the next thing I
wanted to actually also explain is that
I load it into one of the domes a
project that we just finished also it
was like two three months working with
adding grid the the utility on or an
operator they own uniting and their
themselves owned by a board Rolla where
we explored how to use you know mixed
reality both VR and they are on how to
give more intuitive tools for
interacting with the data of
transmission lines for operators that
are just at least the ones that managed
as part of the grid are just a couple of
exits away from the freeway and so we've
been working with them and try to think
about some of these new applications and
in getting students involved and I was
has been great so I'm just clarifying
that when I go into the the last part of
the demo you understand where that comes
from um without Floria to do I will put
on a headset I'm gonna see if this lab
is working yeah and I will change source
to laptop
how are we doing on time oh good I don't
I don't want to I don't wanna get lost
in virtual world and then literally take
it off and you guys are all gone it's my
worst night worst nightmare I think so
I'll put on this headset and I'll take
mostly the role of a tour guide and you
will notice this is not data intensive
we can think of it almost as a canvas
for where your work your data could be
showcased so it's more around perhaps
inspiring us how do we how do we turn a
lot of the concepts that we talked about
today and turn them into immersive
environments or data in context in its
real context we turn put on on these
controllers and all right we're in
inside our first geodesic dome which we
call almost the earth Campus headquarter
and since we are we've been talking
about data on earth wouldn't it be
amazing to be able to interact and see
information about our beautiful planet
in a more immersive and an
contextualized environment some things
that we think about is well well what
are some of the topics that we'd like to
explain that perhaps diagrams that are
key key things that we need to learn
about how temperatures rising in our
planet but but but testing it and in
more 3d 3d models or even understanding
planetary boundaries in a more 3d
setting and as you see here we're in the
main ring of this energy Academy campus
again think about each dome almost like
a chapter in a book or in a textbook I'm
gonna head over to our energy
observatory where I'm so excited about
being here after we
head we just heard Jesse Sasaki talk
about planets and so this these are our
planets in in relation to themselves in
terms of size not in terms of distance
because they just literally didn't fit
into our dome but if we really want to
contextualize this we should literally
just you know take us up and into the
Sun and so the dome fades and now we're
we're looking at the at the Milky Way
galaxy and I'm wondering if I just walk
that way whether I'll find XO exoplanets
but but here it is I mean if we think
about how how can we conceive about
explaining some physics of our Sun these
are some of our first tests of thinking
about whether this is a way to engage
our modern classrooms or even so to
educate data science but also to show
the outputs of our work one of the key
parts that if you remember that Sankey
dragon is understanding the flow of
solar energy towards planet Earth that
in this case is to scale and that's why
we we can't really see it we've we've
tested interacting with different parts
of information for example if we wanted
to learn about the chemical composition
of the Sun or or the physics that we
understand how proton proton fusion
produces the photons that travel or I
can bring up my magnifying glass and
look at the subatomic bonds already
committing in there a hundred and fifty
million kilometers towards planet Earth
a trip that will will stop halfway there
between the Sun and planet Earth to
think about again that those hundred and
sixty two thousand terra watts of solar
energy in flux and constant flux and and
this is a way that we can perhaps
manipulate the sizes that that then
transform into all those different
journeys which are actually not that
many most of it you know gets reflected
and goes back to space part of it gets
absorbed by air and turns into
wind a very small but important part in
support of synthesis evaporation of
water or hydro cycle surface heating so
we conceived of this kind of like exergy
flux model as it many you also for
content of understanding of the the
dynamic between our planet and the star
of the show really so for example let's
look at perhaps a lot of the physics
that can happen here but if we want to
look at the biological part this will
take us to another dome where the focus
is on the photosynthetic metabolism and
this dome is is focus is called our
terrarium on on diving deep into the the
biological world and the way to do that
and explore a lot of that cross-scale
navigation of content we placed a leaf
inside this microscope so I'm literally
gonna go into the microscope and now I'm
standing on that leaf inside the dome
and perhaps this is a nicer setting to
learn about for me one of the most
important metabolic equations that we've
learned since elementary school and and
and even perhaps I can bring up my
magnifying glass and see into the cell
or even better I we've we've tested here
how to be able to go even further across
scale so I'm I'm going to take a trip
down into the leaf think about how each
of these settings can also bring the
story about the outputs of your research
or your work or or what you're
explaining we're here at the the leaf
tissue and looking at cells and and we
can dive even into a chloroplast and in
this model so let's scale into the flora
class into the thylakoid membrane where
photosynthesis happens where that solar
energy gets gets transformed into what
runs most of our biological system
diving into the thylakoid membrane here
we placed almost a model that is
very typical in our textbooks
photosystem two photosystem one ATP A's
and and and here the question is can we
can we explain a lot of these critical
pathways photons from the Sun triggering
an electron excitation the electron
transport chain to produce ATP into a
more immersive context so we're
definitely very excited on testing this
with with professors faculty that are
there in whatever field they are on how
we can use VR both for ed tech but also
to showcase results in a very tangible
way I'm gonna head back up into the leaf
and then go into campus so this will
take me back into the terrarium how are
we doing are you guys still in the room
great and and if we understand at some
of the basics of solar energy and the
role that the biological system has in
introducing it into the trophic system
spiral timeline here is a work in
progress on how do we able to navigate
through some time from the moment we are
now to the birth of the earth to the
moment of the Big Bang
there's there's not much content there
too but I just wanted to show you some
of our ideas and and one of the key
things is also understanding how do we
transition our economy into a solar
based economy and and the electrical
power system has a key role in that so
you know power grid Observatory is where
we nested a lot of the outputs of our
work with adding grid we placed a map
navigator where we can interact through
geographical scales and 2d and the
transmission system of of New England so
that we can think about augmented
reality applications in a place to load
physical devices so this is for example
the operations of a big grid in all the
United States and I noticed that
Oklahoma didn't have any wind farm so we
pumped up this distributed energy
resource pallet so that we can
propose to them that perhaps we could
have a couple of wind farms there too so
this is perhaps the more more
interactive part of the data that we've
we've tested and again cross-scale
understanding is a key part of this
project so we just look at country
operations we can go into regional
Network which of course is where we are
that's that's New Haven right right
around the Haven there's the town of
Woodbridge and we wanted to showcase the
specific micro grid there that I'll zoom
into that but these are just some of the
the wind farms that are close by so if
we go into the transmission system we're
getting closer to the area where
Woodbridge is and these are this is a
specific substation and we've this more
relates to how we can interact with
transmission lines and and see their
outputs visualized in in a more perhaps
intuitive way into the actual
distribution system now we have the
Amity High School which is which is in
Woodbridge and after a hurricane sandy
they placed a fuel cell and turn this
whole section with the Town Hall the
police station the fire station into a
micro grid so that it increases the
resilience of this you know first
responders in the case of another
superstorm but then again why not have
some efficiency to the fire station and
think about distributed energy resource
management maybe maybe a power pack so
that we can do a bit of arbitrage with
batteries and maybe heading over to the
school and on top of the fuel cell that
some solar so a lot of the this this
information is also showing some of the
key outputs of the micro in terms of
generation and consumption and how to
improve the portfolio of devices in this
area we looked mostly at the role of an
operator that looks at the transmission
line 24/7 almost and inspecting
different alarms and pop-ups that happen
of again Internet of Things devices of
devices that are in the electrical power
system so we develop here a concert with
scenario generator tell press on that
and this is what often an operator sees
a series of a Christmas tree of alarms
each alarm is related to a
censor something happened in this case
the scenario produces a surge laws in a
specific area of the power system and so
we suggested to them why don't we use
machine learning to process a lot of our
historical alarms to turn it into more
acute diagnostic remove the noise focus
specifically where the critical alarm is
so that a system can even output to the
operator what happened a thunder strike
with 80% confidence hit the insulator of
a transmission tower and bring in that
that data through for example the Nome
entered a reality had said to the
operator and there's I think maybe a
couple of other scenarios we worked on
for example something around the
Renewable there the regional Network and
the Renewable scale for example the wind
farm producing a system of function
alarm from one of the sensors bringing
in again our diagnostic and literally
say well what's the sensor what's
happening this is this is a problem I
don't see any alarm here but perhaps
there's a specific sensor that is
showing here a main generator bearing is
sending a signal and so perhaps we could
send an engineering report directly to a
to an engineer on the field these are
some of the things that we've been
testing them let me think about another
place to take you but I think that's
that's that's most of the things I
wanted to show the web of science is as
a mere placeholder of what we eventually
think about the content of a project
like this should be able to keep track
of all the the facts or the the
citations that are used to compile
visualize data and so eventually one of
the things we we conceived is being able
to load for example bibliographic
network diagrams and this take us back
to our our our earth
well you're still here um I just wanted
to iterate that that it's it's almost
like an invitation for how can this
inspire us on on how relatively easy it
is to manage the 3d virtual world both
VR and AR use very similar development
platforms so if you have something that
you want to show that you want to both
on your research or one something you
want to learn these might be interesting
tools to to consider well thank you I
think that we have one attempt for one
to two questions before we close
Thanks I thought there was someone
behind me so first of all I can down
this place existed this is wonderful
wait which one the virtual world thank
you for helping me but also this whole
virtual reality thing I mean it looks
really cool to me but to me ultimately
visualization is storytelling and I'm
wondering what does VR bring to
storytelling and what are the use cases
where if you could see things in three
dimensions it's actually going to
illustrate or give us insights into data
that we can't that can't be rendered in
in two dimensions or in traditional yes
I think storytelling is is probably one
of the most powerful things for VR at
least one of the things that inspired to
explore this issue through the lens of
climate change and and our relationship
with our planet is the most of the
things that you know at the core may be
you know obviously the topically
everyone can think about what's that
what's the fundamental problem why our
civilization is driving itself out of
the planet don't and and and I think
part of that is we still lack the degree
of consciousness or awareness so that we
are not separate to it we are an
extension of it we're part of it and
we're strictly interdependent to that
and so in many ways reframing that to
bring bring through education through
higher degrees of awareness a reframing
of the storytelling in our relationship
with our planet perhaps is a key thing
for us to understand that the car I
Drive or whatever my footprint is has an
impact in multiple scales and multiple
layers and that's what I guess I can say
to that out I wasn't sure if there was a
specific question
yeah gotcha so I can't say I can answer
that that question because I think it
requires a lot of a lot of testing and
research into basically the the
education of the pedagogical concept of
it most things said if you have like
data and three-dimensional aspect you
can navigate in your 2d software
relatively well I think that perhaps
this allows and also depending on how
everyone's your linguistic programming
works on what how they remember things
and if you put you inside well perhaps
in the in the context perhaps that
relates you to that what many times when
people stand and in the the the solar
scene they don't really care about the
Sun they just look at the Milky Way and
they're like thank you for letting me be
here and it's it brings up their
emotions and they remember things and
right so so how do we how do we tie this
into a pedagogical process can it
consolidate better how we understand and
graph that that 3d data set perhaps we
we see this as a tool and that those
really is like this is this is an
interesting cool tool some things that
might be working and and many times it's
like well you know for example with with
having grid they were like well if if we
know the output of where the problem is
we can use like mented reality to tell
the operator to go to the place where
the situation is and I say why don't
just use Google Maps right so so it
brings a lot of a lot of fun like oh we
could do this and that but and this is
what happens with emerging technology we
have to test because the the spectrum of
where it's useful where it's not
and with blockchain I can talk for a
while and just watch chain of hi this
and this and so it's still part of the
research of trying or if it's I have a
question so that got me thinking
I feel like the transition from coding
to GUI interfaces actually eroded
people's ability to think
computationally and sort of
problem-solving it made things and
what's your experience with this you
know this is almost like GUI on steroids
in public
Thank You Bennet right and how do we
connect that back to actually the
ability to sequence problems and sort of
the the intellectual analytical chops
that get built when you actually have to
go in through like command-line
interface or code something out yeah
yeah thanks and and and I had a slide
that it didn't show because in some
sense I I tried to also explain where
where we think this fits in a software
stack it's just the graphical user
interface it just allows that if you're
working with big day or machine learning
or block chaining the interface is not
intuitive and so it also limits who we
can reach with this information it
reminds me of what's that that program
that cs50 starts with that you just used
blocks to learn how to code it's
developed by the actually the MIT Media
Lab remember using it and there's a
great success because it's like people
understand how to run code using just
this this piece and to hear it would is
the question is can we learn how to code
in VR maybe I but I think it's tied a
bit to the previous question is can we
use this to first approach approach
newer audiences that perhaps won't
engaged to a piece of information in a
way that it's you know through an
immersive context my relate little bit
more and then perhaps think that if if
you're able to frame the story for
example in a planetary problem that is
and and there's a lot of work in VR for
example for for large social issues
human trafficking there you can see how
we can you know elicit empathy through
VR to then say well I really need to
learn how to code to solve this problem
this is related to the blockchain even
when you're running like a non Bitcoin
operation you still need some kind of
mining operation to be able to generate
the ciphers so what do you see the
entities of controlling those those
mining operations and you don't have a
financial incentive like you deal with
yeah yeah and and it's it's interesting
because in the work of the intersection
of blockchain and energy there's there's
naturally the the huge elephant in the
room saying hey bitcoins carbon
footprint is terrible and my answer
tends to be first bitcoins this
experiment that got at hand it was not
designed for for what mining rigs use
now it's designed to be run on a
graphical processing unit and then went
well actually on a CPU and then went
into well let's use gaming graphical
processing units for this and then go to
application specific integrated circuits
which is what - - so it's changing on
the technological level and it just
shows a bit of different incentives
there it's our responsibility to turn it
into safer protocols in terms of carbon
footprint it's not the only protocol out
there Bitcoin used as a protocol uses
proof-of-work - to deal with the
consensus process of an entry in a
registry there's there's Byzantine fault
tolerance we started we're starting to
work more a bit with stellar which is
more of a FinTech network and uses a
federated Byzantine fault tolerance
system lower carbon footprint it because
we've we've we've already finished our
cycle of hype and blocking so I think
it's almost like now is like oh maybe it
doesn't work for everything so there are
things and a lot of researchers be going
out there to just solve that
okay so let's thank our speakers again
[Applause]
[Music]